what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime opera and today i will be breaking
down what could be one of the most
impactful
boku no hero chapters in quite a while
it appears that an important and beloved
hero may just have lost his life
at the hands of shigaraki and the
potential consequences of this are
already being felt as
deku bakugou and the others struggle to
cope with shigaraki's actions
now this could be a psychot that is
always possible with horikoshi
but by the way that this chapter was
structured it definitely seems that a
major hero character
might have just suffered a mortal injury
there is so much to talk about so let's
get
into it if you enjoyed the boku no hero
content on this channel and you want us
to keep it going please leave a like to
let me know it really does help and if
you happen to be new to anime outpour or
you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications if you don't go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and selecting the option that says
all you're still gonna miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works finally this
video will of course contain
major boku no hero manga spoilers we are
talking about the latest developments in
the story
and they are crazy so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned now the last few
chapters of the story were focused on
everything that was happening near the
villain mansion
and the desperate attempt by the heroes
and hero students to stop gigantomachia
and the other villains from joining up
with shigaraki in jakku
but at the end of the previous chapter
the action switched focus
back to jakku shigaraki was down on the
ground and endeavour was looking pretty
confident
shigaraki was unable to use his quirks
due to the effects of a razer head's
quirk
and so endeavour deku bakugo gran torino
ryukyu and the others were all teaming
up against shigaraki it appeared as if
shigaraki
might be on the verge of losing this
battle
his physical strength is impressive but
the heroes appear to have the advantage
at least for the time being
in the new chapter shigaraki rises to
his feet
yet again and as he does so it is clear
that he has indeed suffered some pretty
extensive injuries
as we saw before one of his arms is
almost completely gone
and he has cuts and wounds all over his
body and yet
he is still moving and still talking
shigaraki defiantly says that heroes
pretend to protect society
but in reality they turn a blind eye to
all the things that they cannot protect
or all the things that are inconvenient
for them to protect
the chapter then gives us a flashback to
when a young shigaraki was distraught
and walking the streets alone as a child
after murdering his own family it was
obvious that something was wrong
he was bloody and visibly shaken but no
one
stopped to help him everyone just
assumed that a hero would come along
and help this young boy because helping
is a hero's job
so why would anyone else inconvenience
themselves or interrupt their busy day
on account of this lost child let
someone else handle it
shigaraki says that the rot of this hero
society comes from within
and all the decay that is about to be
unleashed is just a small
accumulation of the rot shigaraki frames
his destruction
as just the physical manifestation of
the moral corruption
of the hero society shigaraki is
basically saying that the hero society
contains within itself
the seeds of its own destruction it's
almost like a villain version of
dialectical materialism
but instead of talking about the
proletariat and the bourgeoisie like say
karl marx does shigaraki is talking
about the heroes
and the villains he seems to be saying
that the hero society is rotting from
within
and this rot itself creates villains
and then these villains go on to destroy
society and even though nothing
justifies many of shigaraki's actions
we have to acknowledge that he does make
some valid points here
once helping people turned into a job
into something that heroes are paid to
do
then people who are not heroes are not
going to feel the responsibility to help
others i mean why should i take time out
of my busy day to help this kid
when pro heroes are getting paid to help
him the heroes should just do their job
and i'll do mine
end of story in short people who live
within the hero society
rely too much on pro heroes and the pro
heroes system
and because no society is perfect there
will always be people like shigaraki who
slip through the cracks
no one helps these people not the heroes
not the police
not regular citizens these people end up
lost and alone
and they blame society for letting it
happen and some of these people
eventually become villains
just like shigaraki we know that many
other villains that we've come across
like dobby toga twice and so on are also
people who in one way or another
slipped through the cracks they just
didn't fit
into the hero society and so they felt
discarded
and that motivated them to rebel against
that same society
but back to the action endeavour is
having
none of this he doesn't care one bit
about shigaraki's speech
and he launches yet another scorching
attack against
shigaraki however shigaraki is somehow
able to jump
into the air and it appears that his
injured arm
is in fact regenerating endeavour is
shocked shigaraki shouldn't even be able
to move at this point he should be dead
and gran torino notices that the power
of endeavour's attacks has fallen
considerably endeavour must be running
out of steam
after this long and intense fight
against shigaraki
and that is a very bad sign gran torino
jumps in to help
and he attempts to kick shigaraki back
to the ground
but shigaraki refuses to cooperate he
manages to grab
gran torino's leg and the other heroes
understand right away that this
is bad endeavor deku and bakugo
all try their best to get to gran torino
before shigaki can attack him
but they are too late shigaraki grabs
gran torino
and smashes him straight into the ground
as all of this is happening we see a
flashback to the moment when shigaraki's
grandmother
nana shimura decided to give up her son
shigaraki's father kotaro in order to
protect him from
all for one because nana was a known
enemy of japan's most dangerous criminal
at the time
she thought that if the villain found
out about her son he would hurt kotaro
in order to get to her so nana decided
to give him up
and erase all records of the fact that
she was his mother
she did this to protect him but kotaro
resented the fact that his mother
abandoned him for the rest of his life
and kotaro's resentment of pro-heroes
led to his abusive behavior towards
shigaraki which
ultimately led to shigaraki becoming a
villain so
even though nana had the best of
intentions and even though she only
wanted to protect her son
her actions indirectly led to shigaraki
becoming a villain
we also learned that in that moment when
nana gave up kotaro
a much younger gran torino was there and
he was watching the whole thing
from a distance afterwards nana and gran
torino had a very emotional moment
on a rooftop a moment in which the two
of them embraced as nana
sobbed about the difficult decision that
they had just made
in this moment i definitely got the vibe
that gran torino and anna
might be in a romantic relationship and
that gran torino might even be
shigaraki's grandfather however that was
just a vibe that i got
they could totally be just friends and
that might have been a hug from a friend
embracing and consoling his friend in a
difficult moment
so i don't want to make any crazy
assumptions here just wanted to share
how this whole scene
made me feel personally it would be
pretty crazy though if shigaki just
killed his own grandfather without even
realizing although let's face it this
wouldn't exactly be the first time
shigaki killed a family member
back in the present time we see the
aftermath of shigaraki smashing gran
torino into the ground
and we see that blood is flying
everywhere
this doesn't look good for gran torino
and deku absolutely loses it endeavour
warns deku not to rush out and attack
shigaraki
and obviously deku doesn't listen to any
of it because it's deku
what do you expect however shigaraki
doesn't wait for deku to get to him
shigaraki who now somehow seems a lot
faster than before
runs past deku and bakugou and it
appears that he is targeting
aizawa isabel is of course trying to
cancel out shigaraki's quirks from a
distance
and our boy racer head is already
looking pretty damn exhausted
after all of this time in fact manuel
and rocklock are helping him and
literally holding izawa up
as they are walking thankfully as
shigaraki approaches izawa ryukyu is
able to grab him
in her dragon form and just as she slows
him down for a second
deku sneaks up behind shigaraki and uses
black whip to restrain him further
deku and shigaraki struggle as shigaraki
attempts to break free
as this is happening endeavour screams
at deku to hold shigaraki in that exact
position
and endeavour prepares to muster up one
final epic attack
he hopes that he can finish shigaraki
off if he can just squeeze out
one more full power attack but from
everything that we've seen so far
it is unlikely that even this last great
effort from endeavor will be enough
to put chikaraki down for the count but
before endeavour can even attack
shigaraki manages to poke his arm out
through ryukyu's giant scaly hand
and in that moment we see that shigaraki
apparently has a quirk destroying bullet
in his possession and by the looks of it
shigaraki intends to use that bullet on
aizawa
in order to prevent him from erasing
shigaraki's quirks
interestingly enough the final panel of
this chapter
is none other than a shot of arie
looking happy and carefree
and this panel is likely there to remind
us about aries quirk rewind
and to drive home the full implications
of what shigaraki is about to do
we might even get something about aryan
media at the beginning of the next
chapter but we'll have to wait and see
wow this was definitely one crazy
chapter
not only is gran torino possibly dead
not only is gran torino
possibly shigaraki's secret grandfather
but aizawa may be about to have his
quirk erased
by shigaraki let's face it we all knew
that the heroes wouldn't
end this battle that easily and as
expected shigeraki now looks like he is
about to turn the tides of the battle
if he can really stop isabel from
erasing his quirks
then all bets are off so it makes sense
that he would try to make this his first
priority but will shigaraki succeed in
eliminating izawa as a threat
or will the heroes stop shigaraki before
he can reach
aizawa also is gran torino shigaraki's
secret grandfather
and more importantly did gran torino
just die
finally what do you think is going to
happen next is shiraki about to kill
someone else
please share your thoughts down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more boku no your
content on the channel please leave a
like
to let me know and if you happen to be
new to anime outbroad
or you just haven't subscribed make this
the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible an extra special thank you to
alpha a disciple of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget are the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata alolan
adam the world
steelers acquired respect pate heffa
jonathan king brandon aviles papa smurf
emperor otaku
thomas jones and kin mono finally big
thank you to all of our pro hero tier
patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
jason wilson king zeldris anatoly
kazatsky angel
cruz cricket xp joe stanton very gucci
alicia octor jessica kayla fong
hinokami and water bonnie parks wrathwin
deora
deadly saint and stern hawkins if you
enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space
[Music]
cowboys
[Music]
you